[Music] At
first, I had never eaten me, so it was
like Matsutsuki, so I was shocked to run a sushi dish.
[Music]
Funazushi is often said to have the roots of sushi. My name is 1.
My name is Mariko Kitamura. I'm
making sushi with my husband.
Because it has a unique taste, I think the fish version of raw ham and the saltiness are
like 9 caviar.
Masu Eh,
sushi can be roughly divided into two types, such as an early example, but
general sushi can be made faster,
so if you cook rice and put the ingredients on the sushi rice, you can eat it in another day.
In the case of Funazushi, it will be a book, so it will be
a preserved food made by fermenting a ship from Lake Biwa with rice.
This is a local dish of Shiga prefecture.
The shop was founded 400 years ago in 1619.  I'm the 18th generation
sushi, and I'm a very annoying person, but I
also really like the annoying things about
making this outfit.  It's salt-free.
If you neglect these three tasks, it won't taste good.
[Music] It
takes about 3 years for funazushi to become a product from its raw state.
The number of people at home is decreasing a. It's said to be the food culture of Shiga prefecture,
so
we all knew the roots of Funazushi sushi, which can only be made by us
.
You will find a diamond
[Music]